- Ce sont les bureaux
le début de la guerre,
c'est aussi chez lui.
Volodymyr Zelensky ne quitte
presque où il nous reçoit pour
sa toute première entrevue
avec des médias canadiens.
Tout au cours de l'entretien
d'une heure, le président
ne délaissera jamais
À chaque tentative de frappe
aérienne, il est prévenu.
- One sec... Sorry!
- "Un moment". s'excuse-t-il,
alors qu'une nouvelle frappe
est déjouée par le système
autour de Kiev.
De plus en plus, ce sont
d'angoisse et de destruction.
ns kamikazes
à la technologie rudimentaire
L'Iran dément avoir fourni
ces drones à la Russie
un dialogue avec Kiev pour
dissiperations.
Volodymyr Zelensky est
catégorique : l'Iran ment.
ntaines de frappes
sur l'Ukraine, sur la capitale,
sur les infrastructures civiles,
l'université, à l'université
même. ruction de notre
système énergétique pour
que les gens ne survivent pas
à l'hiver. Ils tuent les gens
soit par la faim en bloquant
les voies maritimes, soit par...
C'est ce qu'ils font maintenant.
De quel type de confiance
- L'armée de l'air ukrainiennear
détruit 223 des ces drones
la mi-septembre.
- Je veux le souligner :je ne p,
de la société. Ils peuvent subir
un lavage de cerveau comme
la Russie le fait. Ils peuvent
dire à leurs citoyens qu'int ris
c'est un mensonge, un menson
parfait. Ils tuent notre peuple.
- La diplomatie européenne
abonde dans le même sens et
affirme avoir suffisamment
de preuves qui démontrentlisés
re l'Ukraine
ont été fournis par l'Iran.
européenne claire,
t ferme.
le président Zelensky l'attendaé
internationale sur la menace
ukrainien voudrait que l'onexig,
que la Russie se retire
et mercenaires compris,
de la centrale nucléaire
- Ça doit être une exigence
entier, de l'AIEA,
de l'Europe : demain,
la centrale. Autre
l'agence atomique devrait rompr,
l'exclure de l'org
Il faut des gestes puissants,
Nous n'a
à répondre à toutes sortesls pet
imposer.ontrerontrerontrerontrer
que le monde est plus fort
qu'un te
le terroriste, allez obéir à nos
l'on considère
même s'asseoir et négocier
avec vous.
- Le 9 octobre der Poutine accut
l'Ukraine et son p
d'être responsables du pont
de Crimé territoire
annexé illégalement par
la Russie en 2014 et hautement
symbolique pour le président
russe.ir Poutine
vous a accusé, a accusé
l'Ukraine, vous personnellem
sur le pont de Crimée qui estsux
semaines. Est-ce que vous,
vos savez de sécurre?
- Nous nant que jeant que jeant.
Ils ont un ennemi intérieur.
Les problèmes des relations
entre leurs milita spéciaux dir,
leurs services de
sont aujourd'hui très graves
- C'est dans ses propres rangsc.
- Est-ce que vous
moment vous pourriez revenir à
une table de négociation et
avec Vladimir Poutine?
- Quel est l'intéroi,oi,oi,oi,o,
le président d'un État
personne qui dit quelque cho
et qui change de position
Je crois que l'intérêt de cette
s peuvent
nous redonner notre territoire.s
doivent quitter le territoir
notre pays depuis le territoire.
Le Canada n'a pas accédé à
toutes les demandes d'armes dees
entretiennent des liens étroits
ancrés d
- Nous ne demandons même pas
comment diplomatiqque nous sommt
un soutien, une assurancereconn,
c'est plus qu'un partenariat,ust
plutôt commettre une famille.
- Remercier ses alliés tout enpr
guerre qu'il mène sans relâche
depuis des mois, c'est un
e
préserver le moral et la
motivation de son peuple à
combattre. Il se montree, le
dirigeant inspirant. Il faut
parfois trouver l'énergie,
- Vous pouvez vous habituer à la
vez
vous habituer émot
que je ne suis pas prêt à
m'habituer à notre souffrance,re
se fasse plus mal, ces meurtres.
- Des meurtres pour lesquels le
président ukrainien se dit
devra payer.
Les gens doivent être
responsables de leurs actes pour
cette situation, pour cette
guerre. Il est nécessaire qu